[Music]
so
[Music]
all right what's up mkbhd here
playstation 5 time
so we only really get
truly new consoles every couple of years
i don't know who decided that but unlike
you know the pc world or smartphones
where you get a new incremental update
every year we really have to wait for a
new console and so when we finally do
get that new console
we have big expectations for
generational improvements so welcome to
the full review
of sony's new playstation 5. okay so
we've all talked about this design it's
huge it's an eye-catcher it feels very
intentional to me honestly like it's
supposed to feel like a new generation
they have this black and white motif
going on throughout the whole thing the
controller and the official headphones
and all the accessories even that
controller dock looks like a mini ps5
which is crazy
but yeah it really is actually kind of
risky for them because clearly not
everyone's home aesthetic can fit this
look or work this in without sticking
out and that's the risk they chose i
happen to like the matte white sides
actually the blue led glowing is pretty
cool but i don't like as much the glossy
black middle to me it looks like the
cheapest part and also if you ever touch
it that is fingerprint city but yeah
hopefully you're not touching the
console too much after the first time
you set it up and speaking of setup if
you remember that black plastic stand it
came with from the unboxing video uh
it's meant definitely to be used in both
portrait and landscape or i guess
vertical or horizontal modes
but as you can see i'm not using the ps5
with it on the vertical mode
and i don't think most people will now
technically i'm just going to say you
should use the stand at all times for
ideal airflow and you know they build a
whole swiveling hidden screw design in
there so once you pick your orientation
you can set it up on the stand and never
have to deal with it again
horizontally of course you need that
stand for it to not wobble but
personally i'm cool with it vertically
with no stand it doesn't completely
block the ventilation and it looks great
we'll see if i regret that so do i think
sony made the design this way so it
would be a statement piece in whatever
room you put it in next to your tv
yes
is that a bit of a risk
yes
but i think this crazy design has both a
higher ceiling
and a lower floor for how good it can
look versus something safer like the
xbox one meaning if you put in a room
where it belongs and it looks like this
new modern motif it's going to look
amazing
anyway all right enough about the design
so once you're lucky enough to own a ps5
you'll notice the experience overall
is a few things number one it's faster
it's redesigned and it's definitely
trying to be next gen it is a gaming
console fundamentally so it's still
doing all the same stuff but the ui is
new you know it's got all kinds of
little particles and lights and stuff in
there looks great on a high resolution
tv and even better in hdr
and it's definitely fast just flying
around the menus and the store and
launching games is quick as you'd expect
from a significantly faster ssd now in
this gaming console world it's
practically
heresy to ever compare it to anything
pcs
but i think this is just worth thinking
about for just a second if this if this
playstation 5 was a gaming pc and it's
not obviously it's not but if it was a
gaming pc it would be
actually extremely small number one
it'll be pretty inexpensive at 500 bucks
and it would have a pretty incredible
promise of being relevant for the next
like four straight years and potentially
even getting better over time like it'll
be really hard to find a gaming pc
that's this small
this cheap and this relevant for this
long of a time now there's a lot of
reasons why this doesn't hold up of
course the main one being graphical
prowess of a real pc but if you think
about it that is a pretty impressive
value proposition for a console but once
you fire up that ps5 and actually start
using it you'll slowly start to notice
one by one this next-gen stuff
adding up
one of the big focuses was the improved
specs and the new horsepower and the
faster storage which should hopefully
result in faster load times so it
doesn't have that quick resume feature
that the xbox series x has but it's
pretty close and that's a direct result
of the faster ssd and speaking of
storage by the way i know it says 825
gigs on the box
uh but after the os is installed you
have somewhere near like 670 gigs
just so you know and so when you start
installing some of the big newer games
like some of these files can be truly
gigantic for me spider-man was about 40
gigs nba 2k a little less then there's
some ps4 games but generally they're a
little bit smaller need for speed was
under 30. just something to keep an eye
on the external ssd support is for
saving backwards compatible games only
not for playing them and then
let's talk about the games so the
playstation store shows pretty much all
of the games from last generation ps4
are still compatible which is great and
if you have some ps4 games you still
want to play
they should show up here and it should
work basically exactly the same there
have been some bugs reported but
generally they're going to load and play
the same and then you can even sort by
that in the playstation store so if you
only want to see ps5 only new titles you
can see those that are coming soon or
have already launched and then
ultimately everyone as a gamer is
different i consider myself a pretty
casual gamer so i spend most of my time
in nba 2k and driving games like dirt
need for speed things like that and of
course i played a lot of the new
spider-man miles morales game which is
the launch title for it and some others
just tossed in for fun and then for
other people there's other titles
they've been waiting for there's demon
souls i see gets a lot of hype there's
assassin's creed there's all kinds of
stuff like that and that catalog should
be growing and improving over time
so
as we get into game play
how are the games and does it feel
like next gen gaming well the answer to
that question
it's different in different games let me
explain basically overall we know of
course console quality graphics have
never really touched pc quality graphics
but this time around you keep hearing
about ray tracing and better reflections
and shadows and high resolution and high
frame rates basically what i found is no
single one of these things by itself
makes a huge difference but putting them
all together this stuff adds up to feel
different and that's not even talking
about the controller which i'll get to
in a minute so spider-man morales in my
weeks of testing easily the prettiest
game i've played for sure there's a
reason this is the headlining launch
title for the ps5 and this game seems to
be the best demo of ray tracing with all
the reflections and lighting and
different textures all over the place as
it takes place in a crowded new york
city plus it's in winter so there's lots
of particles again in the air with the
snow and really just whether you're in a
battle with enemies where the camera is
super dynamic and moving around a lot or
if you're just hanging out around new
york city between missions which is
extremely accurate by the way uh there
there's just a ton to look around at now
in this game something a note and i
think this kind of defines the the
console experience this time around at
this level
you choose in this game between high
fidelity mode or high performance mode
you can switch whenever you want so when
you're in high fidelity mode ray tracing
is on this is the best looking version
of the game the textures and the details
are at their highest quality but that's
limited to
30 frames per second
and so here if you look at pretty much
any reflective surface like a window or
some glass
you can see there's some level of real
reflections going on and that's what
we're talking about when we say ray
tracing that's an added level of realism
but if you switch to performance mode
and go to that same spot you'll notice
two things one there's nothing at all in
that glass it's just kind of fake
reflections that move around as you move
it doesn't really represent the real
world behind it at all
and two well this is obviously less
graphically intensive so now you're
running at 60fps instead of 30. so now
everything is much smoother which for a
lot of this game you might be into see
the thing about ray tracing is there's
different uh amounts of different levels
of ray tracing
and so on the ps5 i would describe it as
a sort of partial
ray tracing does that make sense like
most windows and obvious large glass
surfaces they do the reflections which
is dope even this like a storefront
window if you look closely you can still
see it's doing a realistic reflection
and shadow it's amazing
but also some puddles and car windows
are just doing lighting and shadows
without the reflections and so not every
single surface and every model and
texture in the game is super high
quality i think most people though won't
be pixel peeping that much or caring
about that as long as they're like
slinging around through the city and
glorious high resolution on a big tv
like you're not going to be looking at
all that stuff
but at least now you've seen a
difference
for me it's actually kind of a tough
call but i think in this game most of
the time i prefer high performance mode
at 60fps you get that smooth motion
like even without the super realistic
reflections on glass and textures it
still looks pretty damn good and the
lighting still beams off the character
the snow still flows in all the tiny
little particles i love the look of this
game even with ray tracing basically
turned off now in case anyone's
wondering why the pc comparison is still
so far off go back and watch my video
it's linked below about 8k gaming where
we played 8k games at 60fps on the rtx
3090 with ray tracing fully turned on
high quality graphics settings
that's the difference between a pc which
is much bigger and much more expensive
and this
that's all the other ps5 game i spent
more time in was nba 2k 21 and this game
is technically next gen of course it's
made for ps5
but for my fellow 2k players we already
kind of know 2k
is kind of like the iphone of console
games like they make a new version every
year
but it's kind of same stuff just a
little bit different maybe a little bit
better so the gameplay is all still
familiar same controls but for this game
their focus on realism really seems to
be in again ray tracing and like on the
way the materials look so players hair
textures are more accurate and the sweat
rolling down their face and reflecting
the lights all that stuff is more clear
the textures on the court also with
reflections off the hardwood are a
little better more detailed
and even the cut scenes just overall
everything has a little layer of polish
and shine over it this might be a
placebo effect also but i feel like
there are some new animations as well
that are a little more accurate to the
players though still not totally fluid
but it helps that you know everything
seems a little more realistic even
though you can already tell when james
harden is doing james harden things
you can already tell when russell
westbrook is doing russell westbrook
westbrook things
it's just a good time you know what game
you got to play though if you get a ps5
astros playroom i'm telling you you got
it's the best demo of the new controller
that you're gonna see so i've done an
entire video about this new dual sense
controller it'll be the first link below
that like button definitely check it out
but to summarize this new dual sense
controller is sweet it's bigger it's a
little heavier in the hands it has these
quality buttons it's usbc and the
battery life for me turned out to be
pretty good i got two full days of a ton
of gaming before i killed it which is in
line with what i was getting out of a
ps4 controller but the real next-gen
feeling part of it
is the new and massively improved
haptics inside
and the adaptive triggers
so playing through astros playroom it's
actually not even that good of a game to
be honest like you're more just kind of
exploring and wandering around doing
stuff hitting stuff grabbing stuff
whatever you could play for a while and
never really do anything or win anything
but the next gen feel of the controller
haptics making sand feel like sand
through your hands making ice
feel like ice
is amazing and the adaptive triggers
kicking in making it difficult to
squeeze and when you need to compress a
spring really adding and feeling that
resistance as you squeeze them is so
good it's even more immersive to me than
the haptics
the spider-man game to my disappointment
kind of didn't really do much with all
or either of these things i was hoping
spider-man climbing on metal and glass
would feel like metal and glass or maybe
the triggers would get harder to pull if
i was slinging through the city and i
slung through a building that was extra
far away something like that
but there's pretty much none of that in
this game at best you get the occasional
vibration when punching or throwing
things
obviously that doesn't feel at all like
the difference maker on the ps5 in 2k 21
though i love this so in this game you
hold the trigger to sprint right if
you're running hold the trigger
and so in 21 the more tired and fatigued
your player was
the harder it was
to pull down the sprint trigger so if
you're getting back on defense after a
fast break you can feel it's heavier and
it's harder to sprint and throughout a
game it gets heavier and heavier so that
to me
that was good that was a great use
because really the point is instead of
having to look at the screen you're now
feeling when the character is more tired
and that is what makes it feel more
next-gen to me
um nevertheless i i still personally
wish i would see more of this stuff
throughout other games so i played some
other ps4 games like fifa and need for
speed and dirt and of course it's still
doing normal tiny vibrations you would
think like in a driving game the
controller would be going crazy with all
the different surfaces and collisions
but here it's not the ps4 stuff still
feels like ps4 stuff and the ps5 stuff
feels like a little bit underutilized i
think part of it might be that
developers might be a little tentative
to overuse it like they might be scared
of like
scaring people off in a way i've been
told on twitter a lot of people just
turn off the vibrations on controllers
right away
so you don't want to over utilize it and
put too much of it in your game or
people will turn it off but yeah
i don't know i think the triggers are i
think they're
great all right a couple other little
things
so the console is quiet which is really
nice now and a stark difference versus
the ps4 for me which sounded like a jet
after five minutes of gaming under my tv
fingers crossed it stays this way after
years of sitting here slowly gathering
dust and probably not having ideal
airflow with me not using the stand but
yeah so far so good
load times was a big thing to keep an
eye on for the new generation of
consoles i found load times to be faster
but not like some blink of the eye never
see a splash screen again type faster
but it was noticeably faster in every
single game whether it was a ps5
optimized game or even a backwards
compatible ps4 game and that is thanks
to the lightning fast ssd and again it's
one more little thing that adds to the
experience that feels like next-gen
gaming and then i like the slightly new
menu organization the new ui with all
your most recent games in that strip on
the home screen and then the rest of
your library at the end with all your
games and when you press the playstation
button now in a game you can not only go
home or to your normal settings but it
pops up this card view that's pretty
useful for navigating around checkpoints
or different stages or progress in a
game and every developer will use it
differently but some will just show your
level or some trophies others will show
whole tutorials inside this card that
will help you get around but yeah
generally this is a welcome addition i
like it and just generally speaking
i'm a fan of the whole thing i guess as
flossy carter would say the ps5 is a
major
major go if you can get your hands on it
right it's a it's basically a computer
that's
guaranteed hopefully to have a long life
cycle and to improve over time as the
game library grows and that's something
we got to keep an eye on and trust
developers to do but
i think it's happening i'm excited for
it the most interesting piece for me
will be to wait and see how this
controller gets implemented in future
games but as a whole i'm giving a thumbs
up to the ps5 and i can't wait to get
home and
play more games instead of reviewing
games i get to i get to go play games
which is different believe it or not
it's fun
anyway
that's been it
thanks for watching this review and i'll
catch you guys very soon
in the next one
peace